so whether your child is hard-of-hearing
or maybe a parent or even your spouse
let's talk about a potential reason for
that and a real simple remedy okay now
there are two structures in your brain
that control hearing one is the auditory
cortex and the second is the inferior
colliculus
and realize this even though that one
third of your brain runs on glucose you
don't have to consume glucose to get the
glucose your body can make it it's
called gluconeogenesis it can make it
from protein it can make it from fat it
can mobilise your storage sugar and the
mineral iodine is crucial in the
regulation of energy in your body and
think about it what gland controls your
energy production let's all right okay
and what gland
needs iodine to regulate that energy the
thyroid the thyroid makes t4 okay and
then it converts to t3 which is the
active form of the thyroid hormone t4 is
inactive in four and the three
represents the number of iodine
molecules that are that's attached to
that hormone so your hearing mechanism
is dependent on the thyroid and iodine
if a pregnant mother is deficient iodine
within the first two trimesters of
pregnancy the risk factor for
hypothyroidism goes way up also other
risk factors go up the loss of hearing
decrease IQ poor growth and development
many many different things and on top of
that a lot of people are deficient in
iodine especially children in fact 241
million children worldwide are deficient
in iodine so unless you're consuming
like seafood or fish it's very easy to
become iodine deficient simply because
the soils don't have the trace minerals
that they need so very very simple and
inexpensive way to get your iodine seek
help so sea kelp that is harvested in a
really clean ocean would be a really
good source not just of iodine but all
of the trace minerals it's also really
good at amino acids as well and
especially if a woman is pregnant okay
she should be consuming seek help now
some people say they're allergic
to iodine because when they consume
shellfish or fish or something they
break out in a rash it's not an allergy
to iodine directly it's something in the
food that you're eating that's connected
to iodine in that case then I would
recommend going to the health store and
finding a supplement that has iodine
without anything extra and they should
be totally fine
now I put some studies down below that
show some interesting fascinating data
between your hearing and iodine and
sometimes it takes several months before
you can see improvement but if you know
someone that has hearing problems put
them on seek help and see if it can help
them
so if you want to get notified with all
my content click the notification bell
next to subscribed